TARGET.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF AS HE
ALWAYS DOES, IT SEEMS FROM THE
NORTH LAWN.
>> IT'S NOT MY FAULT.
I SWEAR.
AS YOU SAID, OFFICIALLY THE
MEETING IS STILL OFF, THERE IS
BEEN NO ANNOUNCEMENT TO THE
PRESIDENT'S CANCELLATION LETTER.
BUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DIPLOMATIC POSTURE, IT WOULD
SUGGEST THAT UNOFFICIALLY AT
LEAST, THIS MEETING LOOKS LIKE
IT IS BACK ON.
LEAVING WASHINGTON ON A
ROAD TRIP TO TEXAS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP THIS MORNING
GAVE A THUMBS UP TO HOW TALKS
WITH NORTH KOREA OR PROCEEDING.
>> GOOD MORNING, I WANT TO TELL
WITH NORTH KOREA.
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE HAS HAD A
VERY GOOD MEETINGS.
HE IS MEETING AGAIN TODAY.
I BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL BE
COMING DOWN TO WASHINGTON ON
FRIDAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT REVEALED TODAY
THAT THEY ARE EXPECTED AND
DELIVER A RESPONSE FROM KIM
JONG UN LAST WEEK.
>> A LETTER WILL BE DELIVERED TO
ME FROM KIM JONG UN, SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT IS IN THE
LETTER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP LOWERING
EXPECTATIONS FOR HIS PLANNED
MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN, SAYING
IF IT HAPPENS IT MAY BE JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS.
>> HOPEFULLY WE WILL HAVE A
MEETING ON THE 12TH, IT IS GOING
ALONG VERY WELL.
BUT I WANTED TO BE MEANINGFUL.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT IT GETS
DONE AT ONE MEETING.
MAYBE YOU HAVE A SECOND OR
THIRD.
MAYBE WE WILL HAVE NONE!
>> THE PHRASE MAYBE WE WILL HAVE
NONE COULD ALSO APPLY TO ROBERT
MUELLER'S REQUEST FOR AN
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> I WANT TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS
THAT TREY GOWDY HAS NEVER SEEN,
WHICH IS OUTRAGEOUS.
I WILL NOT LET MY CLIENT
TESTIFIED.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S OUTSIDE
ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI TOLD
FOX NEWS TODAY THAT HE HAS TWO
CONDITIONS THAT NEED TO BE MEANT
TO BE FOR AN INTERVIEW.
ACCESS TO ROD ROSENSTEIN
SO-CALLED "SCOPE MEMO" OUTLINING
THE AREAS WHERE ROBERT MARLER
WAS ABLE TO INVESTIGATE AND ACCS
WAS ABLE TO INVESTIGATE AND ACCT
WAS ABLE TO INVESTIGATE AND ACCO
DOJ MATERIALS WITH THE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANT WHO
APPROACHED SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> IF AND WHEN WE FIND THAT THIS
WAS HANDLED APPROPRIATELY AND
THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE ON WHICH
THEY COULD BASE THE PHONE THE
INVESTIGATION, WE WILL HAVE HIM
TESTIFY.
BUT IF THERE IS NO EVIDENCE,
WHICH I ASSUME THAT THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE, THEN I MEAN, HE SHOULD
NOT TESTIFY.
>> THE LATEST TWIST REVEALED IN
THE RESTAURANT INVESTIGATION IS
THE EXISTENCE OF A MEMO WRITTEN
BY FORMER FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE ABOUT THE FIRING OF
JAMES COMEY.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT
McCABE MEMO DETAILS A MEETING
HE HAD WITH DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN.
SOURCES SAY IN THAT MEETING, ROD
ROSENSTEIN SAID THAT THE
PRESIDENT ASKED HIM TO INCLUDE
SOMETHING ABOUT RUSSIA AND HIS
MEMO JUSTIFYING JAMES COMEY'S
FIRING.
ROSENSTEIN TOLD McCABE THAT HE
DECLINED TO DO IT.
A SOURCE TELLS FOX NEWS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIMPLY ASKED
ROSENSTEIN TO ADD A LINE ABOUT
JAMES COMEY TELLING THE
PRESIDENT THAT HE WAS NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
THE REFERENCE WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN ROSENSTEIN'S FINAL MEMO.
>> RUDY GIULIANI ALSO TELLS
FOX NEWS THAT HE HAS NOT YET
BEGUN FORMAL PREP SESSIONS WITH
THE PRESIDENT FOR A POSSIBLE
INTERVIEW WITH ROBERT MUELLER,
BUT EVEN IF THERE IS NOT GOING
TO BE AN INTERVIEW, RUDY
GIULIANI SAYS THAT HE WOULD DO
THE PREP SESSIONS, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM WILL WANT
TO WRITE A REPORT ABOUT IT AT SM
TO WRITE A REPORT ABOUT IT AT SE
POINT.
AND THEY NEED TO HAVE A GREAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL, AND THE
PRESIDENT IS UNDERSTANDING
BEFORE THEY WRITE THE REPORT.
BRET.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED A PARDON, HINTING AT A
MORE ACTION TO COME.
>> DENNIS DESOUSA, THE
WELL-KNOWN CONSERVATIVE
FILMMAKER, AUTHOR, AND
PLAYMAKER, PLEADING GUILTY TO A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION RECEIVED A
PARDON TODAY, AND THEN ABOARD
AIR FORCE ONE ON HIS WAY DOWN TO
TEXAS, THE PRESIDENT SUGGESTED
THAT THERE MAY ALSO BE PARDONS
IN STORE FOR MARTHA STEWART AND
FORMER ILLINOIS GOVERNOR ROB
BLAGOJEVICH WHO IS SERVING THE
14-YEAR PRISON SENTENCE FOR
CORRUPTION.
INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT BOTH OF
THOSE PEOPLE, THEY APPEARED ON
"CELEBRITY APPRENTICE" THIS DID
NOT SIT WELL WITH SOME OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CRITICS THAT BELIEVE
THAT HE IS SENDING THE SIGNAL TO
PEOPLE CAUGHT UP IN THE RUSSIA